bon les chéris on va revenir et on va
revenir bien sûr sur tous les bails déjà
les réactions et on va revenir déjà sur
l'audience merci à tous puisque hier le
record historique de complément
d'enquête a été battu très largement
puisque regardez on a les on a les on a
les dernières audiences regardez de de
complément d'enquête voilà non les
dernières audiences voilà il y avait
PPDA 1ion7 c'était le précédent recur
après Magalie Berda 975000 sopia che
kirou 1100 déchets nucléaires 549000
ouais 1 million pour meurtre espion et
franc-maçon violence conjugale police
741000 et hier 3 millions de
téléspectateurs pour complément
d'enquête 32,9 % de PDA c'est le record
historique jaces cardoou ouais c'est
celui de la chaîne aussi à cette heure
là que tu exploses aussi le 23h minuit
du jeudi soir c'est ça voilà quoi qu'il
arrive donc c'est sur France 2 il y a
jamais eu un score comme ça un jeudi
soir c'est le record historique et de
mémoire à l'époque de Benoît les très
gros scores c'était 22 23 il y avait
beaucoup moins d'audience sur la TNT
donc tout était beaucoup plus concentré
sur les premières chaînes donc c'était
plus facile à l'époque d'atteindre des
scores plus élevés là franchement c'est
franchement c'est stratosphérique c'est
voilà c'est c'est énorme mais en prime
time ça aurait fait combien 4 et demi je
pense ouais voilà c'est ça c'est dingue
je pense en prime time 4 4 million demi
après voulez pas mais 3 millions c'est
vrai que c'est c'est incroyable quand
vous avez vu les Scor ce matin vous
étiez étonné ou pas g moi je pensais de
ah ouais Guillaume hier on s'était dit
de tris je suis quand même étonné mais
vu
l'effervescence vu l'engouement
médiatique vu l'attente finalement on
avait nous-même sous-estimé et je suis
pas aussi surpris que ça voilà après ce
ce qui est assez fou c'est le score sur
les 15 34 ans parce que la moyenne de
l'émission c'est je crois que c'est 59
ans et demi et celle de la chaîne c'est
62 ans et demi ou 63 ans donc là
performer comme ça sur cette tranche là
B ça ça veut bien dire que quelque part
alors on va en dire encore que je te
sire les pompes mais ça veut dire
forcément que c'est une partie de ton
public qui va voir ce que complément a
fait sur toi enfin moi je l'interprète
comme ça 15 34 ans c'est pas l'habitude
du tout de de le ça on t'a dit de le
dire ou c'est
toi franchement j'ai j'ai tous les
vendredi matin j'avais c'est très bien
fait les les audiences elles sont
détaillées par par plein de catégories
et la catégorie des jeunes on sait très
bien que les émissions d'info on les a
pas
il on sur france télé ça dit quoi j'ai
eu des infos moi de France Télé il
paraît que voilà le le patron de fr télé
a dit que c'était un score historique
qui était incroyable ce matin il
s'attendait pas à autant même Tristan
valex qui que j'ai eu il s'attendait pas
il s'attendait plus autour d'un million
ils son ils sont surpris ils sont
surpris mais ils se disent
rétrospectivement que voilà comme nous
que c'est pas si étonnant parce que vu
l'engouement et cetera mais ils ont été
un peu débordés par par le score c'est
c'est vrai que les réseaux sociaux aussi
ont amplifié tout ça les gens sont tous
venus tous ven la première fois que
France de en deè partie de soirée fait
quatre fois pratiquement le score de TEF
à la même heure c'est vrai que c'est
c'est un truc de fou pour eux voilà donc
merci en tout cas à tous ceux enfin qui
on regarder pour pour moi pour me voir
et tous ceux qui on regardai pour que je
me fasse
fracasse l'audence va continuer
d'augmenter parce que tu sais
aujourd'hui que il a il y a le replay il
y a ce qu'on appelle l'audience
consolidée donc dans un mois ils vont
publier des chiffres officiels sera 3
millions et demi 4 millions 5 millions
enfin voilà alors on va revenir bien sûr
sur tous les points dans dans un instant
juste avant j'aimerais savoir je vais
vous dire un petit peu les les réactions
il y a le Figaro Magazine qui a dit qui
a fait un article pétard mouillé nul
zéro perte de temps des téléspectateurs
très déçu par le complément d'enquête
sur Cyril hanuna il y a énormément de
tweet he c'était un beau pétard mouillé
je trouve que le complément d'enquête
sur Cyril hanuna est très nul et médioc
trop à charge pour rien et pas de fait
concrets quel gros flop ce complément
d'enquête au final l'argent public le
vôre le NRE le mien on serv expliquer
que Sira est un homme qui a des amis et
des ennemis et qu'il aime l'argent et
que sa maman ira en prison pour lui vous
ne rêvez pas il est comme
vous voilà il y en a plein et puis il y
a énormément de de rigolades force aux
personnes qui ont dû sacrifier leur
temps de sommeil pour au final être déçu
euh voilà je pense même qu'anuna est
déçu du complément
d'enquête complément d'enquête ou plutôt
un reportage sur le le bateau de ConA
sérieux c'est déjà fini ils sont où les
dossiers sur le boss du PAF c'est juste
un béan pour dire qu'il a réussi sa vie
n'hésitez pas à mettre les illustrations
en régie merci euh aucun mec qui ne
réussit qui réussit n'a pas le droit de
s'acheter une villa et un bateau vous
êtes vraiment des tocar avec votre
enquête en bois de de cagette
ensuite il y a un truc qui a marqué les
téléspectateurs c'est c'est mes insulte
euh sur les tweets vous savez puisque
Bengal était même en TT hier puisquils
ont ressorti un tweet où je disaisre du
bingale Arthur que je lui mettais un
tigre du bingale dans le dans dans le
fondement
la mortadelle et le tigre du bangal qui
se demande ce qu'ils foutent dans le
fion des gens suivez en régime TL non
non voilà gen le tigre du Bengale quand
il a vu où cyil Anouna voulait le mettre
mettez le tigre s'il vous plaît
l'illustration le tigre du Bengale qui
n'a rien
demandé pour épargnez le cul du
charcutier on vous dévoile nos
meilleures recettes à la à la mortadelle
regardez regardez bon c'est ils sont ils
sont à la ramass
les chér il faut mettre la photo merci
sur TikTok il y a eu aussi pas mal de
réactions et le constat et celui-ci
regardez cette première réaction regarde
complément d'enquête c'était quoi ça non
attendez attendez il son on est resté
éveillé pour ça je vous ai dit je savais
qu'on allait être déçu je savais ils
l'ont mis dans la sauce de rien du tout
frère en fait ils ont juste dit des
trucs qu'on savait déjà Cees
chroniqueurs il leur faisait la on
savait
déjà très
drôle c'est très drôle regardez on a une
autreéaction aussi d'un très très vénère
m plus qu' bande de chien Gal que vous
êtes bande
d'imbécile vous m'avez tenu en all toute
la journée je suis resté éveillé les
yeux et bail jusqu'à 23h j'ai commandé
45 € bande de chien qu'on a appris qu'on
ne savait pas déjà voilà il est minut 36
je suis restée éveillée demain je dois
aller au travail je dois déposer ma
fille à 7h du matin je vais être dans la
je vais me réveiller le pied à gauche la
tête à droite le nez en bas comment je
vais faire j'ai j'ai pris des sushis
c'était tellement nul jusqu'à le poisson
il a failli ressusciter foutez de ma ou
quoi on vous a fait même monter l'udimat
pour
rien meilleur alors il y a fa qui aé
tout du long il était pas comme un ouf
c'est fini l'émission c'était une blague
il y a une partie c'est pas possible
l'histoire du y est intéressante un
patron goût simple dit l'ex salarié et
il ne veut pas faire de la publicité sur
sa vie privée mazette maintenons
question qui paye de
reportage ce que je retiens de
complément d'enquête c'est que j'ai
offert un voyage à Miami à des mecs que
je connais même
pas àid Turner le complément d'enquête
d'hier soir et son cortège de chouineuse
tout droit sorti d'une cour de récré a
montré ce que le journalisme peut
produire depuis médiocre ah là là la
jalousie cœur sur cyil et toute la team
qui m'ont permis d'aller si largement à
votre rencontre my dear fans
et et et et certains ont commenté cette
publication il n'aurit pas dû parce que
Afida en rou libre MD mdr parle il
rachète ta carrière avec un kebab tu te
le mets dans le cul et
celui et celui de ta mère la mergaise
hariss au contraire ce reportage est
fort révélateur ça confirme que
l'opinion publique pense votre pense de
votre mentor un avis c'est comme un trou
du cul tout le monde en a un
qui qui a autorisé la pouf à s'exprimer
ton cul voil il Jér Kiel qui a réagi
également très drôle son tweet un an
d'enquête et un tel battage médiatique
pour en arriver à sortir un brouet
insipide il doit bien se marer à Nouna
euh il y a chikandier honnêtement j'ai
regardé l'émission hier comme tout le
monde j'ai pris du sa j'ai pris du
sopalin des popcorn j'avais même mis mon
chaufsexe et ma
gourmette et là là bon nada nente Maka
schalou Cyril peut se montrer ferme
parfois ah il lui arrive même de menacer
des gens par texto euh oui comme tous
mes weekends après avoir vu mon ex quoi
et il a signé un gros chèque avec
Vincent Boloré non sans deck je croyais
qu'il bossait à l'œil honnêtement moi
Nouna c'est pas ma cam mais je m'en
cague lui c'est la grande distribe et
moi un petit épicier du coin qui galère
à fourguer son lit périmé mais là
l'arnaque c'est pas Nouna ce sont les
fameux journalistes d'investigation
honnêtement c'est comme si une meuf te
chauffe t'emmène aux chiotes et
finalement te propose un
Pépito il a Sarah Salman également vu
les commentaires une une fois de plus
que complément d'enquête c'est un gros
tesing pour rien apprendre Hugo manien
journaliste qui est déjà venu sur notre
plateau qu'on aime beaucoup c'est
curieux j'ai été témoin du contraire à
plusieurs reprises des invités venus de
province don moi sur l'une des émissions
sont très bien traités parfaitement bien
accueilliis par les équipes de
production euh et il a mis tout ça pour
ça allez bonne nuit